antoine bonjour la russie continue donc
de venir en aide au pays elle est plus
durement a frappé par cette pandémie
c'est bien ça oui tout à fait après
avoir envoyé ses avions de matériel mais
aussi de spécialistes vers l'italie
vladimir poutine a proposé l'aide de la
russie à donald trump pour fournir aux
états unis des équipements médicaux afin
de faire face à cette crise sanitaire
c'est le président américain qui a
annoncé la nouvelle dans un premier
temps hier lors d'une conférence de
presse alors qu'il se félicité de
l'échangé téléphonique qu'il venait
d'avoir avec son homologue russe écoutez
nous avons eu une super discussion avec
le président poutine nous avons eu une
super discussion avec le prince héritier
d'arabie saoudite si nous avons aussi
discuté plus avec le président poutine
du virus car la russie est durement
touchée et nous avons discuté de
beaucoup de choses du commerce
nous avons discuté de beaucoup de choses
tous les deux une information par la
suite commenté par le porte parole du
kremlin
tandis que les états unis sont à l'heure
actuelle le pays le plus touché au monde
par le cos vie 19 dimitri peskov espère
que washington saura s'en rappeler si la
russie éprouve à son tour des
difficultés sanitaires dans les semaines
à venir je vous propose d'écouter le
porte-parole de vladimir poutine dans un
contexte de grave situation
épidémiologique aux états-unis la russie
a offert une assistance sous forme de
matériel médical et de moyens de
protection
le président trump a acceptée avec
gratitude c'est aide humanitaire
il est important de noter que en offrant
son aide à ses homologues américains le
président poutine part du principe que
lorsque lé fabricant américain de
matériel et d'équipements médicaux
prendront de l'ampleur
ils seront également en mesure de rendre
la pareille si nécessaire et même si le
porte-parole du président russe a
remarqué des réticences du côté de
l'administration américaine a accepté de
l'aide venant de la russie
vu l'ampleur de la crise il n'y a pas je
cite d'autres solutions que d'agir
ensemble dans un esprit de partenariat
et d'assistance mutuelle
merci beaucoup antoine gayraud pour
toutes ces précisions antoine claireaux
notre correspondant rtl france à moscou